logan paul and Chloe Bennet have split
we love each other it's to get the word
out there love it crap hashtag Logan
passionate Logan a source confirm the
news to et that the 26 year old actress
and 23 year old YouTube star are going
their separate ways the pair first
ignited dating rumors in 2017 after they
co-starred in the remake of valley girl
ET was on set and saw their chemistry
firsthand I mean or a couple another
space
so not know just a lever one yeah it's
just valley well you shouldn't do people
you actually like yeah right the pair
strongly hinted they were more than just
friends on Logan's vlogs in my opinion
friends sometimes make eyes touch spies
Chloe stood by Logan side throughout his
YouTube controversy earlier this year
after he aired a vlog that showed the
body of an apparent suicide victim Logan
and I connected on a significant level
early on and I think that you know
people make mistakes and if you can't
have room to grow from a mistake and if
can't forgive people despite changing I
don't think really we have anything I
think I think growth comes from making
mistakes I don't I've never known anyone
who's grown just from being perfect
Logan posted a sweet tribute to Chloe
thanking her for her loyalty quote she
stuck her neck out for me risked her
career and personal friendships and
chose to help me grow seems like you
guys have good chemistry can you can you
respond to that comment we do we do we
do a really good chance to do
[Music]